[Applause]
the best most outrageous and memorable
looks of the 2018 Met Gala first up met
gala co-chair Rihanna shut down the red
carpet
sticking with the heavenly bodies
fashion and the Catholic imagination
theme in her strapless Pope inspired
Margiela artisanal dress by John
Galliano the pearl and crystal
embellished three-piece gown and
headpiece took a total of 250 hours to
sew and 500 hours to hand embroider Amal
Clooney who also served as co-chair of
the event wowed in this dramatic
metallic floral print corset matching
skirts and navy pants alongside her
handsome hubby George Clooney next up
ariana grande looked heavenly rocking a
custom strapless Vera Wang gown
[Music]
she's wearing Sarah Jessica Parker wore
an elaborate Dolce and Gabanna gown her
headpiece a chapel and inside a full
miniature nativity scene Paris Jackson
stepped out in a stunning Sienna pleated
silk tulle gown by Stella McCartney
party B showed off her baby bump in a
cream along sleeve Moschino by Jeremy
Scott gown encrusted with pearls and
jewel toned crystals she paired the look
with a matching custom jeweled headpiece
while Katy Perry who's known for giving
us many memorable Met moments was
angelic in an extremely large pair of
wings Scarlett Johansson attended
fashions biggest night wearing an ombre
Marchesa gown a unique choice after what
seemed to be an unofficial boycott of
the company which was co-founded by
Harvey Weinstein's ex-wife Georgina
Chapman Jared Leto was Jesus like in
Gucci and Blake Lively looked like a
true fashion goddess in this custom
Versace deep red silk velvet gown with a
crystal encrusted bustier cascading into
a dramatic full skirt with an oversized
embroidered train and see-through pants
[Music]